foreign
seek vengeance
but their enemies are already at the
gate
the pack of 20 will not back down
Intruders turn their Eden into dust
second Karma invades foreign lands
as fractures grow within his own family
all will fight
[Music]
but only one will rule them
Circa Karma gambles everything on a
hunch
the drought destroyed their Marsh
now he leads his family into unknown
hostile territory
his Queen matsumi trusts him
[Music]
but he'd better be right
his crown and their lives are at stake
[Music]
okay
this is nothing like home
[Music]
not so easy here
each miss undermines the second Karma's
Authority
his oldest son sirketti
is just waiting for him to fail
mistakes can kill
but sakakama believes he's on the right
track
[Music]
keep moving
there's no turning back now
[Music]
the pack of 20 holds the last remaining
Waterhole in the North
they've been here for Generations
they know this land
something's not right
quick
gets the pups to safety
the king is here
his Queen's advance
everyone else can leave
secacama's gamble pays off
he delivers an oasis
even his harshest critics drink to their
father's success
[Music]
abandoned Queen of the North Sato knows
that call
bloody Tyrant
second Karma exiled her and her sisters
to this Wasteland
to raise their seven Cubs
in poverty
foreign
still craves Revenge
but a young pride is not ready for war
not yet
sakakama would destroy them
[Music]
the king makes himself at home
he knows food is drawn to water
like moths to a flame
thank you
his loyal Queens maneuver a victim
right into the Trap
[Music]
this is sakakama's prize
beautiful
no one dares question
[Music]
but his oldest son is conflicted
so Ketty is hungry for power
but drought is no time to revolt
there are other heavyweights in This
Strange New Kingdom
[Applause]
play The Good Son and lead the Cubs to
safety
this should win you favor with father
letting his rebellious son stay is at
risk
but second Karma can use a good
Lieutenant to weather these troubling
times
the pack of 20 won't be bested by
bullies
this is their land
confident
they form a ring of Terror around the
Waterhole
and have their pick of prey
foreign
strategy and numbers ensure their
success
every frenzied kill is a theft from
sucker Karma
the pack of 20 will stay here and take
all they can
[Music]
until they win back their water hole
sekakama is going nowhere
foreign
wait for their next victim
I grows impatient
he's ambitious
the chip of the old block
on the friends can be unpredictable
what is this
battle scarred and unafraid
that wants to share our Oasis
the Cubs have never seen anything like
it
[Music]
foreign
yields
he never shows fear
is this a in his armor
is the old man getting soft
refugees once again
the northern Pride lies low
satta has come too far to give up now
[Music]
burning with Revenge she goes it alone
foreign
um
it's a buffalo don't yet know the
respect due to their new sovereigns
they'll learn
they have no idea how delicious they
look
[Music]
foreign
nice try
Now watch how it's done
oh
Father and Son claim victory together
a volatile Alliance
but one that could save them all
[Music]
the Marsh pride is bloated by their
success
off guard unvulnerable
unaware of a cold-blooded killer lurking
in the shadows
thank you
satao hopes to find the king in trouble
an opportunity to settle the score
oh how wrong could she be
this is suicide
all alone with her mortal enemies
she's at second Karma's Mercy
foreign
[Music]
's mission is a humiliating failure
will ring in her ears forever
[Music]
the marsh Pride's success fueled
circadia's confidence
he learns from the King himself
the rush of power at his father's side
is addictive
[Music]
okay
someday second Karma will fall
[Music]
and said Kitty
will be there to take his place
patience
dominance has a downside
[Music]
now only the brave or the foolish dare
to come close
the Queens keep Vigilant watch
even Petty thieves are dealt with
foreign
murderer spree is turning this land
into their own death trap
[Music]
food no longer comes to them
the feast is over
but sucker Karma's young cubs demands do
not stop
[Music]
he has no choice but to search
and he needs the whole Pride's help
[Music]
there's not a heartbeat out here
so Cody sees no point to this
[Music]
foreign
Nation will not be tolerated
how dare you
foreign
or leave my pride
go
lick your wounds
the family's Feud does not go unnoticed
thank you
the pack knows how to keep their cool
but other tempers flare in the brutal
Heat
foreign
[Music]
s to share the news
The Mask pride is divided
this is their moment
only a brooding and bruised security
guards their Waterhole numb
time to move in and take back what's
ours
but a wounded ego can be a dangerous
thing
foreign
Prince against a pack of 20.
he could kill them
but where do you begin
without backup from father
sir Kelly loses his nerve
The Water Hole goes back to the dogs
[Music]
they misjudged their adversary
he is not alone
[Music]
foreign
did you really think it was over
[Music]
the prince returns with a full force of
the throne
are they your pups and get out of here
[Music]
the pack is powerless
underestimate a ruthless foe
and pay a terrible price
they've lost a brother
a son and a priceless sodia
[Music]
it's too dangerous to stay now
they have to leave
for a life on the Run
foreign
this land is now just a graveyard
only Giants remain
foreign
the Aging King faces another terrible
Gamble
follow the herds into hell
or stay
and pray something turns up
[Music]
all right
roll the dice one more time old man
sacchetti watches eagerly
their father fails
he will be ready
he looks to his brothers to forge a
rebellion
[Music]
three on one
could topple a weakened King
sakakama decides
they will stay
[Music]
but only monsters come here now
foreign
he knows better than to take on this
Beast
it's not that old
but it's untouchable
sirketti sees opportunity
if father won't do it I shall be the
hero
he's leading the family into a fight
they cannot win
this monster is far too dangerous
thank you
made it
so Caddy's awkward attempt to lead only
reveals the limits of his ambition
karma is no fool
he's seen him plotting with his brothers
thank you
there is a penalty for treachery
this is my pride
remember who killed your older brother
foreign
ERS are quick to beg forgiveness
and pledge their loyalty to the king
without his brother's support sir Kelly
has no chance
but sakakama still allows the rebel to
stay
he has need of him
foreign
together could they take down a giant
just one
and that would feed the whole family
normally untouchable
the drought has left them tired and
weary
nervous
and vulnerable
[Music]
the seed is sown
wear them down
[Music]
foreign
thank you
even if it takes all night
Darkness only fuels their Terror
this is where sucker Karma excels
foreign
[Music]
together
they have the muscle
[Applause]
all they need is one mistake
[Music]
tonight
is the night
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
Victory is more than just a meal
it's a Triumph
with security by his side
he achieves the unthinkable
and delivers
salvation
but now the job is done
His Rebel Son is redundant
the storms are coming
[Music]
there's no room at the top for two
thank you
sir Kitty must go
for good
but second karma is unleashing a monster
[Music]
the future Monarch from his own Royal
stock
his blood pumps with the wisdom of a
king
power
of a god
a second Karma
the best is behind him
his son however is entering his pride
when cicadia returns from exile
no one
not even sucker Karma
will be able to stop him
[Music]
foreign